hey guys I'm Ilana welcome to my channel
today I'm playing alien isolation on the
Xbox one but before we get to the actual
gameplay / face cam part of this video
there are three things I should brief
you guys on first if you don't want to
hit the three things the gameplay starts
at two minutes so you can just skip all
of this stuff one there is swearing in
this video sorry about that - I haven't
seen the alien movie since I was super
young which means that I may not do a
very good job of explaining 3 which is
that I've cut out the first eros of
gameplay here because it was just really
boring you spent a lot of time walking
around looking for things and there's
very little action so it just wasn't
very entertaining so I got rid of it but
because you guys will have miss the
start of the game I thought I'd try to
briefly explain the plot so far to fill
you in
you play as Amanda Ripley a
weyland-yutani technician and the
daughter of Ellen Ripley who has
mysteriously been missing for 15 years
the flight recorder for Ellen ship the
Nostromo has been found and is being
held on a space station called
Sevastopol so you had there with two
other weyland-yutani employees but some
explosion II thing happens and you will
get separated so you get to the station
alone and it's all empty and busted and
there's like graffiti everywhere and you
wander around for a while until you find
a guy named axel who offers to help you
find the communications sector of
Sevastopol so you can contact your ship
the Torrens to tell them what has
happened you head through some tunnels
and stuff with axel avoiding some other
hostile humans who seem to be kind of
like bandits or scavengers and then
eventually hit one of them over the head
and Axel shoots them to kill them
because they were trying to kill him
that basically brings us up to speed I'm
going to show you guys a quick cutscene
here and then the ever sweary alien II
gameplay begins
something on me I don't know I don't
know what it was but I guess this is
where we finally tracked down any lien
maybe I shouldn't be running okay
not running moving very quietly
oh Jesus okay that tells shut lights
flashing I don't know what they can see
and what they can't see yet but but but
open [ __ ]
let's call transit sure and then [ __ ]
hide because that's probably gonna be
noisy
better what's happening anything I said
does it come yet the thing that I called
oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh Jesus
why is the music
escalating Oh God I don't understand why
is
why are you doing this to me something
oh god please don't let there be
something in there [ __ ] okay okay okay
we are currently living oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay was that I assumed
that wasn't that was supposed to happen
that wasn't supposed to happen
Oh what the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
there then
thanks for the achievement dick bag I
don't want achievement for that [ __ ]
all right give that I know the girl I
don't know if maybe there's somewhere I
mean here to hide know that I can see
all if I was able to shut the door on a
transit maybe see maybe hiding and that
would be great but I don't know if this
is time to based on when the transit
comes or that it probably is let's be
real or if it's just timed unfortunately
those safe points a kind of far apart
I want to kind of don't want to screw
this up which I guess it's part of the
appeal of the game really is that
the noises though is that it does anyway
in there
I don't think so
I don't think so Jesus I'm part of the
yeah part of the stress of making the
scariest that it is like that but
overall really I don't like to game that
looks for really guys on Scotty cut
I guess we'll have to see pop this music
okay I'm transits open still sitting
here I'm not walking in there I feel
like this [ __ ] is gonna come and
super know as soon as I open it it's
gonna be timed right walk so what do I
do when I get in there I don't know
is there a door to shut
what that well that was really simple
then wasn't it
let's just wait through the glorious
creepy cutscene I suppose I feel like
this game would be a lot more effective
if the lights were off but then the
camera wouldn't work and as you guys may
know I've kind of like debated using a
camera or not but but will the purposes
of this I feel like it would be
effective because I'm very expressive
facially and I thought it might be
entertaining so probably gonna cry out
which phase it's opening this way okay
and let's be real this place is gonna be
[ __ ]
swarming
okay savvy thingy yes hello there
I would like to insert my emergency
driver into your [ __ ] girl okay
let's see where we have to go what place
solutions doesn't sound right really
what's this system cystic wall beat you
okay potion run I'm gonna crash the
whole game though how like transit
system
okay
it's locked
hmm hey friend Hey thank you for letting
me into your very shrink too like I
can't see
huh I guess this is where we go there's
someone here it's the person sir
well you act
Oh honor
really you show me that easily
son of [ __ ]
I should go fishka fishka
hmm well I guess I mean Bailey ins on
you I prefer for human to like shoot me
then for an alien to kill me aqui
gosh different is it
Donna so should I know what that is
oh no I wasn't oh oh no no I wasn't I
was not doing anything
I don't know you are right right okay
okay
yeah yes go downstairs do that
that's great idea that's where I still
am if I had the world believe I don't
want to kill me about it like bird we
can scavenge together have you not heard
about the serious alien problem going
down here we can just gimme buds no you
could communicate now hiding there a
real good time everyone wins
mm-hm
oh god no no no no no no
all right well this one's new year I
wonder if the other humans can get in
these places it would make sense if they
could but yeah let me some bonding agent
about that bonding and agents mmm-hmm
all right yes hello well I don't know
plasma torch [ __ ] I mean yeah [ __ ] your
plasma torch what's that
really though a lot of this game feels
like a little wandering around not
really being sure what I'm doing it's
like a well disguised fetch quest which
kind of annoys me but you know we'll see
how eager
Oh God Oh
well I supposed to do now I don't know
the plasma torch which I'm supposed to
have apparently I don't know what you
want from me bro oh [ __ ]
we shouldn't have done that feel like
that would be obvious well okay so maybe
I just have to like track track their
movements but it's [ __ ] Dan not the
power stands for ever I saw one look at
you you think you're ready to shred a
guitar like I feel like surely they can
see me through here right but the Brum
isn't enough I don't know where they are
do they come up on a map or anything
then it's like hard to track find a
daughter so that way huh I mean it's
gonna be really fun to get through here
without knowing where they are at any
point in time
but I suppose that's part of the fun of
it is uh
you know just really just constantly oh
[ __ ] me you shouldn't not goes this way
maybe I could knock him out from behind
the west cheek oh I know you're talking
about I'm not right here in in in plain
sight
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no I'm just gonna be I don't know maybe
proudness man nothing it was absolutely
nothing [ __ ]
you serious come on